hi I'm chance I'm playing a show I am
principal night and I want all those
hearty caring and death in the Tampa
area to come out and see our show Sam
found me through by the route there I
was interpreting for a dram and chance
was backstage watching and you got what
that I never seen an interpretation
happen like that before
we just wanted and then you look at the
deaf community right so we have like our
own rapidly moving that goes athlete but
he's signing - okay this is it - my name
is Mac nasty
I'm the video creators founder
definitely dope being a hip hop language
interpreter well outside that knowing
and the Jewish standard excited would
interpret so your mission is to really
make sure that this audience who's never
really experienced listening community
can fear in a way that they can relate
to it with their language but they can
also understand it in its own context
without it being
you know somebody say turn up at the
club I think of how he looked in the car
people are good let's go so I'm thinking
that's how I would define or so what you
mean to turn up to cut it by fine turn
up it doesn't look the same it doesn't
have the same effect compared to it back
there hurry up DNA not for imitation DNA
an abomination
[Music]
I got my hearing aids another tooth that
I've always had in a whole time growing
up college when I was 18 my first time
really starting to learn hip-hop back
with like my heart left to just try to
practice on my own just go that I could
keep up with regular conversation and
then I'm good right okay sign-in tolling
is ddr2 and then people would see me
time Thunder it'd be like oh that's cool
there's providing hip-hop music to
another culture that never really had
the chance to experience it before
there's nothing out there to really feel
included but why not create something to
where people can feel included and not
just be a
[Music]
you
[Music]